>> ♪ ♪
>> NOW THE EVER STRUGGLING JOE
BIDEN WAS CAUGHT IN ANOTHER
BIZARRE MOMENT THIS WEEK.
AFTER CLAIMING HE USED TO DRIVE
AN 18 WHEELER SEMI-TRUCK AM TAKE
A LOOK.
>> ANYWAY.
I DROVE AN 18-WHEELER, MAN.
>> THE ONLY PROBLEM THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE HE EVER DID.
THE WHITE HOUSE CLAIMING THAT
BIDEN DID RIDE IN AN 18-WHEELER
IN 1973.
BUT OF COURSE, IT GETSINE WORSE.
-- GETSINE WORSE.
BIDEN CONFUSED DONALD TRUMP AND
BARACK OBAMA AND COULD NOT
REMEMBER THE 3 REASONS HE RAN
FOR PRESIDENT IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO I WAS RUNNING FOR THREE
REASONS.
ONE TO RESTORE THE SOUL OF THIS
COUNTRY.
SECONDLY TO REBUILD THE BACKBONE
OF THE COUNTRY.
HARD WORK AND MIDDLE-CLASS FOLKS
WHO BUILT THIS COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT ASKED ME TO NUMBER
CHARGE OF MANAGING THAT PIECE,
THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP EXCUSE ME.
THAT WAS THE LAST PRESIDENT.
ANY AT THIS TIME WAY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN I WAS
VICE-PRESIDENT.
>> JOINING ME WITH REACTION ARI
FLEISCHER AND CHARLIE HURT.
ARI FLEISCHER, DO YOU BELIEVE
THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE SAID HE
USED TO DRIVE AN 18 WHEELER?
>> [LAUGHING].
HE USED TO BE A RACE CAR DRIVER
TOO.
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN HE IS NOT
PLAGGARIZING HE IS LYING ABOUT
HIMSELF AND DOING IT FOREVER.
I JUST PULLED THIS UP.
IT'S SO EASY TO FIND.
ARRESTED IN SOUTH AFRICA AND
FINISHED IN THE TOP HALF OF HIS
LAW SCHOOL CLASS.
GOT AN ACADEMIC SCHOLARSHIP.
NOT TRUE.
SAID HE WAS THE FIRST IN HIS
FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE WANT NOT
TRUE.
-- HE SAID HE PIN A NAVY STAR ON
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T WANT IT.
NOT ONE SENTENCE IN THAT WAS
TRUE.
HE SAID HE GOT HIS START AT A
HISTORICAL BLACK COLLEGE
DELAWARE STATE.
HE DIDN'T GO.
THERE.
HE IS A SERIAL LIAR.
>> THE THOUGHT OF HIM SITTING
DOWN WITH PUTIN.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THOSE GUYS ARE
THINKING SITTING ACROSS THE ROOM
FROM HIM?
>> I THINK THEY ARE PROBABLY
VERY RELIEVED THEY ARE DEALING
WITH THIS IT GUY NOW INSTEAD OF
THE LAST GUY.
I WONDER IF AFTER 4 YEARS OF ONE
OF THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
PRESIDENTS IN MODERN TIMES
ACCIDENT IT'S LIKE THE SWAMP IS
BACK TO MAKE THE ARGUMENT IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHO IS
PRESIDENT -- EVEN THIS GUY CAN
BE PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE SAYS THE
DUMBEST THINGS AND IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
IT DOES MATTER WHEN HE SITS DOWN
WITH THE LEADERS OF CHINA OR
RUSSIA OR THE EUROPEAN UNION.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
THE REAL THING THAT IS STRANGE
ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN AT THIS FOR
50 YEARS IN WHICH THE POLITICS
FOR 50 YEARS.
RUNNING HIS MOUTH FOR 50 YEARS
AND RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT MOST
OF THAT TIME AND HE IS REALLY
BAD AT IT.
HE IS TERRIBLE AT IT.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHETHER HE DROVE
AN 18 WHEELER.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID IT WAS
A SCHOOL BUS.
IF HE DOESN'T KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE, WOULD YOU LET THIS
GUY BE IN CHARGE OF ANYTHING?
THEN HEY SAYS THINGS LIKE THE
FREUDIAN SLIP.
HE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
IS.
THE MOST BASIC THING.
WHEN YOU START OFF TO LIST THREE
THINGS, YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO
ALWAYS LIST THREE THINGS.
THAT'S MY POINT.
HE IS SO BAD AT IT.
HE SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN OUT A LONG
TIME AGO.
>> THE SHAME IS WHEN HE IS
TALKING ABOUT THE THREE THINGS,
WHEN HE GOT INTO THE RACE,
NOBODY THOUGHT HE COULD WIN.
THE PLAN WAS HE WOULD WIN.
ARI FLEISCHER, YOU TRAINED
ENOUGH POLITICIANS.
THOSE THREE REASONS, WHY DO YOU
WANT TO RUN FOR THIS?
THE GUY DOESN'T PAST THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTALS AND NO ONE IN THE
MEDIA CARES.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON HIM?
>> WELL, THIS IS WHAT BOTHERS ME
SO MUCH.
A PRESIDENT ABOUT TO TURN 79 AND
QUESTIONS SHOULD BE RAISED ABOUT
HIS MENTAL HEALTH.
YOU WATCH HIM IN A SPEECH IN THE
NEWS CONFERENCE TODAY.
HE CAN BE SHARP.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
HE CAN GO BACK AND FORTH WITH
REPORTERS AND GIVE LUCID
ANSWERS.
BUT WHEN HE GETS THINGS WRONG
TOO.
THERE SHOULD BE A SCRUTINY.
THE PRESS SHOULD COVER IT.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS SEEN
FIT TO GIVE HIM A TOTAL PASS.
THEY DON'T HOLD HIM TO ACCOUNT
WHEN HE MAKES UP LIES ABOUT
HIMSELF.
THEY JUST CHUCKLE.
THEY MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PRO-BIDEN STORY THEY WRITE.
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO PROTECT AND
COVER FROM HIM INSTEAD OF DRAW
ATTENTION TO HIS FRAILTIES THE
WAY THEY WOULD ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT?
>> THE IDEA OF JOE BIDEN COMING
OUT AND SAYING WHAT DO YOU WANT
IF HE IS BUILDING BACK BETTER
AND EVERYTHING IS GREAT AGAIN.
HE BLAMES EVERYTHING ON TRUMP
THAT HE DOESN'T THINK IS GOOD
LIKE OBAMA BLAMED EVERYTHING ON
BUSH.
I DON'T REMEMBER THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS DOING THIS.
BLAMING THEM ON THE DEMOCRATS
BEFORE THEM.
ALTHOUGH I COULD BE WRONG.
I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN JOE BIDEN COMES OUT AND
SAYS I AM NOT SUPPOSED TO TAKE
ANY MORE QUESTIONS, HE STILL
CAN'T STOP SAYING THAT.
THEY MUST SPANK HIM OR SOMETHING
WHEN HE GOES BACK FROM A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> WELL, THAT'S THE ONE PART
ABOUT BEING A POLITICIAN HE IS
VERY GOOD AT.
VERY GOOD AT BLAMING OTHER
PEOPLE FOR HIS MISTAKES.
ARI FLEISCHER PUT HIS FINGER ON
SOMETHING IMPORTANT.
THE FACT HE CAN BE LUCID IS
ALMOST MORE OF A PROBLEM OFFURE
DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE GETTING
LUCID JOE BIDEN OR INSANE JOE
BIDEN -- THAT MAKES IT MORE
FRIGHTENING.
IT RAISES THE QUESTION:
IF HE IS ALL OVER THE PLACE IN
TERMS OF HIS MENTAL ABILITIES
AND HIS ABILITY TO BE WITH IT.
THEN WHO IS ACTUALLY IN CHARGE
WHEN HE DOES LOSE HIS MIND?
IS THERE SOMEBODY THERE?
WHO IS THAT PERSON?
THIS IS A FREE COUNTRY WHERE WE
ELECT OUR LEADERS.
WE GET TO PICK OUR LEADERS AND
KNOW WHO IS IN CHARGE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS
IN CHARGE WHEN HE IS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS EATING ICE CREAM
AND TALKING ABOUT A FANTASY OF
DRIVING AN 18 WHEELER.
IT'S ALARMING.
>> HOW DOES H